- Everyone has a problem with time.
But, the day is 24 hours and we sleep six.
Now I know there are
some out there that say
oh woah, woah, woah, woah, I need eight.
Well I say, just sleep a little faster.
I went to school, I was
working in construction,
I was working out my five hours a day,
I was taking acting classes
from eight o'clock at
night to 12 midnight.
I was doing all of those things.
I wanted to make sure that
out of the 24 hours of the day
that I don't waste one single hour.
Those hours were too precious.
And so then I just want to tell people,
don't give me this thing,
I have a difficult time
with the time, and I don't have
time for this, none of that.
You have time, you make the time.
(heroic music)